this session will be continuation of the session from
what was it?
Wednesday
But we're going to look at.
the applications
of Matrix and Vector operations to
computer graphics
So if you remember in our last session we
started with the vector
operations.
Factor addition scalar multiplication
we talked about the dot product.
I give you some code.
or drawing vectors on
coordinate system really was just mathplotlipinos drawing.
Lines on onto the onto the
plot. Well, we will revisit that code in a moment.
We also talked about the polar coordinate system.
And how we would go from the Cartesian
coordinate system to the polar quad
systems if you wanted to for example, move a
vector.
from the origin
by some
angle
And you know, we had to we had to talk about going from Cartesian to
Paul according today. We will also go the other way around.
So we're going to continue talking about the vectors.
and
something called linear transformations
so let me
write down the item, so
review of code
or vector operations
talk about linear transformations
transform
And then the applications.
of
Transformations which geometric transformations
and of course we want to do an exercise because we didn't do any in our
last session.
But we'll do next exercise and if there's time maybe I'll also, you know,
go all the way down to trigonometry.
Something that I want to look at.
I think I'll make it an assignment is to
implement these trigonometric functions with
python.
So trigonometric function sine cosine tangent
can be approximated with series.
I'll talk about that later on but those series
can also be implemented with python and so you can measure the
the ratio of any two lines
to get the angle
of
to get the angle of any line.
Okay, but we'll cop that later on. So it's a good it's a
good way to read not truly understand trigonometric functions because
you know trigonometry is all over.
linear algebra
And anything you do with?
Vectors and matrices in particular Graphics. Okay,
let me return to the code here.
So if you recall.
that is if you
were there in the last Workshop because I uploaded the videos.
Only yesterday so you may not have seen this if
you were not there on Wednesday. But anyway.
this notebook
was for practicing
working with vectors
And visualizing them.
So at the very top of this file, I'm importing math cloudlib
and numpy.
And that's all we're using in this notebook.
Then we talked about visualizing.
two-dimensional vectors, okay
So here we have.
PLT figure in PLT access
this will allow us to
embed a plot into our notebook.
and the ax object will allow us to
well, you know modify the axis of
the of the figure.
Here we're setting the limits.
so
for the and so here we have access to
the two top quadrants quadrant one and
two.
So X goes from negative 15 to 15. We'll rest for the y-axis. It
just goes from 0 to 10. We're not going to leave this.
Leave this region.
We have the vector function which will take.
a tuple
doesn't have to be too cool. It could be a list. It just has to
be a some data structure with two elements.
Where the first element is the X point and obviously
the second element would be the white point.
And we use the lens linear space method from numpy to
create space of values.
from
the starting point to the Finish point. So for example,
here we have vector.
0 5
so this and by the way
here, we assume that the displacement on the x-axis is
zero.
so
where the where we started displacement we take zero Steps
From the x-axis.
And of course here the wide display Smith is also assumed to
be zero. That's the default value.
so
we don't move from the x-axis, but we move Five Points.
on the y-axis 2 3 4 5
and this function creates 100 points from 0 all the
way to five.
Okay.
So this vector?
Had we plotted the one like this one this V1.
This V1 vector.
we would get this blue Vector if I
comment out these
The vectors two and three and I run this code again. Let me
run it from the top.
Okay.
So you can see.
We started zero and we stay at zero.
I mean we started we stay with state
zero but on the y-axis we go all the way up to five.
So for example if I had set
v127
it would go from 0 to 7.
So to the right?
And then five points to the top so we'll get
this.
You know slanted.
Bacteria, and it will it gets something that looks like.
this
okay.
Now I also learned you don't actually need 100 points
to draw two lines to draw a line.
I said that you actually need to draw 100 points. But you're
actually you just need the starting position the starting point and the
endpoint.
So we would need something that looks like this.
You would need.
x sub 1
and y sub 1
come on now.
and except two
So this would be P1.
And this would be P2.
Okay.
So we just need these two points.
I've made a hundred. So if I actually bring these down to two.
would have
the
Starting point for one line segment and the ending point.
So I just set these back to two bring these back to two.
It will work just as well. So this is P1 and that's
P2 and I'm doing this because of what we're about to get
to later on. So we're going to continue on this code and to
look at geometric transformations.
Okay.
So that's the vector function.
this produces
two points
so x sub 1 and x sub 2
and obviously this will produces.
Why someone in y sub 2?
so together
You know, we're going to form a tuples. So this
this first element in this Tuple is going to be x sub
1 and x sub 2 together.
That's actually going to be a list an array rather.
And this one also what we array, so this will contain why sub
1 and 1 Step 2.
So column column this will be column that will
be a column.
Then we have to draw function which will take a vector.
basically
this over here now take that Vector OBG just
refers to the access the ax object
from math public and then if you want you
can displace the vector.
And that's just for the color.
and here
this is just for extracting the points.
From the vector specifically if you
have a vector.
And that's your vector. So let me write this
in math notation your vector for example of these
1.
And of course we have to use the correct.
mathematical notation you in
this python implementation. You actually going to have the following.
Let me write down the code.
The Matrix
you would have
x sub 1
and
Y sub 1
x sub 2 and Y sub 2
and B Matrix
Yes, so your vectors are this.
Now when you pass this
V1 as an argument.
to the GP function you are going to get
these two
these two values so the ending point.
Why because we can use
the GP function to get points function to perform
vector addition.
Okay.
So for example here, that's a second vector.
So let's let's make a v the vector
one will go to the right.
A vector 2 will go.
to the left
typical in the second quadrant
and of course when I say quadrant, this is the first quadrant.
That is a second quadrant.
We draw those two vectors.
There's our V. And of course if we add them together.
To add two vectors, we will take the points of the first vector.
The points of the second Vector add them together in a
third vector.
And then the length of this Vector is obviously the sum of
these two if we had multiplied it would have been the multiple of
these two vectors.
So that's two dimensional now for today. We're not
going to go into 3D not in this session.
but
Very quickly. This code was it's just an adaptation
of the code above except this one produces.
The Z point so we have three points so R
to the R3.
Okay, this is a vector over R3.
or an element in in R3
So it's the same functions, this is 3D. This is
3D. This is 3D and then, you know, can we control vectors Network 3D
dimensional space? So we're not going to really deal with this today.
and then of course, we looked at cosine similarity
which
you know, we said it's used to
Which allows us to compare the similarity of two vectors and
I give you an example with wood vectors.
Right. So the first let's say we have these three word vectors each
element represents the probability of that word
belonging to a particular topic.
The topics are t1234 for pets
mammals anesthesia and building respectively.
So we have these two word vectors.
You can see they're more closely. They're closer to each other than the third
one.
and so we used
we again borrowed the back and draw functions
from the previous cells.
And I showed you how to calculate the cosine similarity.
So cosine similarity.
Takes two vectors. That's this function takes two vectors.
The numerator we have the dot product.
And the numerator we have the product of their magnitude.
And again to calculate the magnitude.
You square all three or all n elements of
the vector?
And then you take the square root of their sum.
You will get the angle.
so here
we have three word vectors, correct?
So this is the first and what we and here
what we choose is to compare.
Word to and War 3 against toward
one. So we want to compare what it was
with one dog or cat.
World one was dog. Yeah, so we want to
compare cat.
Which is this red line?
with dog and then building
compared against
dog
So when we compared the word Vector of cat against talking
you see we have a smaller angle.
Whereas for building in dog, we have a bigger angle
a wider angle.
and that's how we establish the
the
similarity
this is used in topic modeling this so if
you have a document.
And you want to put it under one category you can.
convert it to
you can create three vectors. So we've done we have just done that obviously
with these three vectors these cannot
be pointed on the plot.
So what we do is we create three vectors.
Like we have done down here.
here
this is the vector for word one.
and then the vector for
War Two compared to one and Vector 3
or words three compared to word one.
Up here. What we've done is we've calculate the cosines similarity of
word one versus word two. So this will give us an angle.
This will give us an angle.
And this will give us the angle of word one versus word three.
Now, of course, this will only works if we plot it on if we had a polar
coordinate system. We don't have a polar coordinate system.
You have a Cartesian coordinate system. So if we go if you want to go from Polar
to coordinate.
Here's what we do we take the length.
of the
of our lines
Which are directors?
multiplied by the sign of the angle
so the sign of the cosine similarity after we calculate cosine similarity
will get Theta
plug in Theta multiplied by the radius of
the vector
and that will give us the point on the x-axis.
Take the cosine of that angle multiplied by
the radius and we'll get the point of the y-axis.
So basically
X and Y
Are these points here?
Okay.
cosine similarity of board one and four two
Will give us X and Y.
Here for cat. That's this point over here.
I mean all the points by the way start at the origin so we
don't need to worry about the first point.
for all three lines
It's 0 0 0 0 so X
Y zero zero.
But the ending point ending position.
is given by
this formula
where these what is that is the cosine similarity.
Okay.
I did talk about giving you another a more
elaborate example with.
Autocomplete, but I just haven't been able
to unfortunately.
But I will come back to it.
so
This was an application in 2D space.
For cosines there today. We want to look at something called
linear transformation and its applications in geometry.
And the later on we can extend.
We can go from 2D to Matrix to Matrix
operation.
so I'm about to give you a very briefly that the
formulation for linear transformation and it
will come back and look at its applications in.
you know in
geometric transformations of imagery
Okay.
so let me make a copy of this file say as
You know call this.
transformations
And I don't need.
These two cells. So I'm Gonna Keep 2D and I'm gonna lose the
others.
Okay, so linear transformations.
so linear transformation
is a function
here we use a here using map notation.
So f is a function that goes from RN to
RM.
now a linear transformation can take you from
R3 to R3 or
R3 to R2
so you can actually go from three point to two points or three points to
3 points you can
Change the transformations.
Now this will a linear transformation holds or
a linear transformation is a linear transformation if these two conditions
hold.
For example, you have two vectors UV and V.
Then if you take the sum.
of two vectors and remember from abstract from
from tutorial 8
we talked about the following. Let me copy this.
Paste it on top. This is from the other tutorial.
And thank you Richard for correcting me on the scalar multiplication. So
I confuse scale a multiplication.
I call them matrix multiplication when I was really referring to
the dot product.
anyway
we said that the sum of two vectors will also be
A third Vector, which means whatever this is, let's
say we get a vector W that will also be an element
in V. So it's gonna two vectors give you a
vector.
A scalar multiplied by Vector gives you a vector.
and the dot product
because and this is how you perform a DOT product just multiply the
elements of both
vectors.
Take their sum and you will get the inner product.
We'll also be a vector.
so
the sum of the two vectors, which will also be a vector must be
equal to
that transformation
of the
of each vector
separately
I mean exactly what you're seeing here.
This condition must hold for addition. And of course this condition for
scalar multiplication must hold.
So for me to elaborate, let's consider these two
examples.
Here we have example one an example. So this is one example.
The comet in the chat. Let me look at the comments.
Did we Define?
Capital italic v as the euclideanian space
Vector space it's a it's it's it's the set of vectors.
V is the set of vectors
Okay.
So here's a here's an example of a transform linear
transformation.
Okay, no particular reason for using application by
the way, but let's say this is the lead. So this
is map notation. This is function notation.
So is this a we want to see if this is
a if this is a if this function could be a linear
transformation for two vectors.
of course, these are two elements of a vector but
it's still applies for vectors as well.
here if we take
and just to avoid confusing the
variables because it's valuable can
also stand for the sum of two variables. Let me
use a different letter here.
for example
I will use let's use U.
Okay.
So, let's see if this is an example if this is if this
is a lean transformation so you we will replace with X Plus
Y X Plus y
So this one argument will be you.
Well X Plus y squared so if we
substitute X Plus Y into U will get X Plus y squared.
Which will give us this.
You know.
quite Relic expression
now if we take f of x and F of
Y separately
f of x will give us x squared.
So we replace x with u?
And for wide replace you with Y, we'll give
us x squared plus y squared and clearly this expression
and that expression are not equivalent.
So this is not a linear transformation.
This is an example of a function. That will be
a linear transformation.
Well, and how do you prove that? Well, you must evaluate right you
must.
Take X and Y over 2.
And then to take f of x of this value and
then if y of this value, but anyway if you do the algebra.
You will see that.
They will be equivalent. So what I'm trying to say is this
G of again, I'm going to substitute x
with u just to avoid any confusion if I
would take x g of x
Plus y
and then we do some algebra.
Dot if you do the algebra, it will turn out that G Plus
X.
plus G Plus y
or equivalent
Of course.
Both of these conditions must hold true, okay.
So you have to check for that and check for this.
Let's look at an example of a linear transformation and also
matrices can be
we can also do linear Transformations on matrices.
So let me also add this comment.
This idea of matrices as linear transformation will come.
And to play once we talk about once we return
to the topic of systems of linear equations.
and of course computer vision
So our discussion today has applications and finance.
and
computer vision later on
when we get to neural networks.
It was everything by the way a new network is a
matrix.
Everything in neural networks, and neural networks are the
infrastructure for deep learning.
It's all Matrix operations. We're going to look at we
we're going to look at a matrix operation
that we haven't talked about like the chronicle product the convolution.
Which is another way of multiplying two matrices together.
But we'll talk we'll get get it there later on. So here's an example of a matrix.
As linear Transformations, okay.
we have a times X plus b, so imagine we have a
system of linear equations
here B
Is what the equations equal to?
so if you remember from linear program we had
I think 2x plus y equals 4000.
So anything's the right of the right side of the equation would be in
there in the in the B vector.
Anyway, if you see here, we have two that we have a matrix The
Matrix a
which is a two by three Matrix and the vector.
Which is well.
Three dimensions. It's we have three dimensions three
points multiply this Matrix and we
go from
Three vectors to objective with
three elements to a vector with with with two elements
from R3 to R2.
Okay, we will use we will very soon build upon this
to.
And return to it once we look at more elaborate computer
vision applications.
So today we will work with the vectors.
Later on, we will work with matrices.
And I don't know if we might have time to do this. But if we
don't do it in live session all add some
Code notebook so you can look at later on for cubes.
for geometric transformations in the in the three-dimensional
plane
Okay.
Let's return to the notebook for transformations.
And let me create a new section here.
Call this linear transformations.
Okay, this is
Three, okay.
So I'm gonna scroll up here and let
me just yes and math is imported. Just making
sure everything.
Okay. I'm going to borrow this bit.
Close that.
And I'm gonna go from 10.
to 10
also on the y axis.
So 0 will be the middle of our plot.
PLT is not defined.
PLT is not defined because I need to run these cells. So
let me run them all.
Okay, so when we draw
vectors, we're going to draw it.
here in the middle
Okay, let's look at let me draw another. Let me draw a vector to
get started with.
Here we have V sub 1 again from before.
Okay, again, I've created this functions
to obstruct them away. So the origin of this
Vector will of course be zero.
So if we set this to zero, that means you're going 0
steps from 0 well
That means you're not going to move anywhere on the x-axis or
you have set it here to four.
And since our origin for the on the wax, it's also
it's also zero that means four steps up. Anyway,
you basically you draw a vertical line.
And if I want to draw this Vector, I'm going to go draw.
V1
I need to set obj to the ax object.
And there's my line.
If you want me to make it taller I can just make it
10.
Make it down to wait.
Okay.
So let me show you some what are an example of some geometric
transformations.
And I have a PDF. I want
to show you.
type saved here
Where did I put the PDF?
It's faster than me running it down.
Copy pasting the code.
Okay.
Any second now?
This is one but I think I had I think
is the one.
Let me double check.
And I had another one.
Okay, this I'm going to keep yes. So this this I'm going
to show you but there was another one.
This is from Cornell. This other one is from
I think you see Urban. It's just taking a while to load.
Oh.
yeah, so for example, this is an example of going from
the two-dimensional space to three-dimensional space
so that this is a linear transformation.
Okay, so if you want to project a plane.
It's in a three-dimensional space. You can do that. Obviously
this has applications and computer vision.
And computer vision is a subset of machine learning.
These are the conditions we talked about.
Where is the
The transformation that I this is
the one yes, so here look at this one.
Let me show you.
I'm gonna we're gonna go through some of these let me begin with the dish
for example this year.
This is the sheer transformation.
So for example, if we have in our case, we have a straight line.
Yes. Now, of course a matrix or I
should say a plane.
is
You can imagine it being a moth a multitude
of vectors.
I will show you in the code what I mean, but I want to show you how we can
take these transform these geometric transformation matrices.
to modify
The shape of our vectors so we will start with
the vectors later on. We will look at transforming matrices doing exactly what
you're saying here.
like skewing matrices
you know when you use Photoshop if you ever use Photoshop
You know you can skew.
a picture
You know, like if you if you're trying to put you know, someone's head
on the body of an elephant, you know.
This is what you're doing. You're doing Matrix Transformations. Okay, so
let me show you how for example The Matrix tissue. Okay
here stands for the degree to which you want to skew or
you want to apply sheer to the play.
I prefer gimp. Oh, of course. You can also use gimp.
Okay. Now I I to me, this is particular interesting because I'm
trying to create a new network.
or
detecting math symbols
In PDFs in a PDF, you really
can't just extract text because of the encoding.
And one problem you have with the math literature.
Is for example, let me show you if I can pull up
an example. This can be a problem. So relevant
to take this discussion, but let me know. Let's say you have like a
paragraph of text and then there was a like I
mention of the variable X.
Now I want to trade the new network to to distinguish
between X.
You know.
from some English sense
and when it's used
in reference to some variable.
In an equation somewhere in the page.
So you have to be very acutely aware of or the model has to be acutely aware
of the
How much land there is in the letter?
And of course, yeah, if there's it's on the background of a
picture or a background of diagram.
isolated so if computer vision is, you know something that's
interesting to you if you want to do OCR
If you want to do, you know.
Like in autonomous vehicles being able to detect what's on
the foreground. What's the background?
You know, this is this is this is relevant. Okay, let's
begin with the basics. We will eventually get to that point later on.
So let's let me show you how we can
apply.
Shear to this line, okay.
That's our Vector. I'm going to create here
a transformation matrix. There are unicodes for
a math symbol. The problem is when they pick them up.
No, no Unicode. I actually
want to be able to search equations.
So I need to convert the books.
or the
a PDFs eventually will be in the form of
picture. So I have to do scan those PDF pages.
Like they are pictures and then turn them eventually
to latex code later code is exactly what you know
what I use here because with latex code I can index it.
So it basically I'm going to make a search engine for
books. I would write it Write a math equation expression.
and I'll get
search results. Google actually does this.
Google doesn't impressively well if you want to if you search for a formula
with in latex code Google will pull up web pages
and even pages from books.
There's there's Google books, which is a repository of books and it
will pull up the page.
Which is pretty pretty cool. So if they've done it, it's certainly doable,
but obviously, yeah.
That's closed Source. I'm trying to make it.
Make my own anyway.
So this is our vector.
and
if I type it out here we will see.
Okay, I I this is I don't want 100 points.
If you remember I said we can make it only two points. So let me modify this
code.
I thought I deleted this little.
delete this
delete that.
one more time
once more click on all
yeah.
so
this is x sub 1 x sub 2.
y sub 1 y sub 2
so
X goes from x sub 1 x sub two
they're all on the same place, but for why we go from
y sub 1 to Y sub 2 that's
that's eight.
I'm able to use some grip.
post later
Yeah, I have no issues with
the searching the latex part. It's the converting PDF to
lighting part. That's tricky now. There is something called Matt picks math
mix is very good.
but
first of all, it's closed source and
It doesn't work. When you when you want to scan the full
PDF page. If you take a snapshot like a
paragraph within a page, it's fine, but I want to
scan entire pages of books.
And I want to have a database of 100 books. So the
great part is fine. It's the going for picture to latex.
But I'm getting close to a solution. I'm getting close to it. And I'm
going to show you part of the I'm gonna We
Will We are gonna talk about new light works
and computer vision in module 4, but let me come
back here. So
I'm going to multiply this Matrix.
With a transformation matrix, so I'm going to go look at
my code here.
And let's call this shear.
and this will be a two by two just like
in this presentation from I think
this is UC Urban.
Make sure to give them credit.
Where was this year this year?
That's the one.
So I want to go NP
dot array.
and if you remember from the LED composition session
We said that this is an identity Matrix.
This says key Pro 1 as is.
And this one says keep row two assets. If I
had done one here, then we would be multiple.
multiplying or rather adding Row
1 to R2
if I do this and I multiply
V1 it's called a vector but it's really
a matrix right because x sub 1 except to Y sub 1
y sub 2 but anyway, if I multiply these two together if I do if
I use the mat.
Multiply method. So this is
my original vector.
I'm going to say V1.
V1
I think when you apply transformation use apostrophe.
I can't use apostrophe here. So I'm just going to use.
transform
and this will be NP mode multiply.
So the transformation matrix must come first. So
Shear times V sub 1
And then I'm going to draw.
the vector after I have
applied some geometric transformation
So the original one stay let's make the original one
black.
C equals black
and the transformation will be red.
C equals red
now I just complaining because
different dimensions different dimensions
yeah, because this has to be
A list this has to be honest.
Let's try that again. One, two three.
Okay, and yeah, so obviously the red
is drawn over the black one because this is still an
identity Matrix.
If I want to she read if I want to make it slanted left
or right I have to change.
this element
So let me try to and of
course we have to keep in mind our access goes and increments of what is
this 2.5?
So if I wanted to go 2.5 I was gonna
make it 2.5. Let's see what that does.
Okay, that's a lot. Let me make it.
less than that 0 Maybe
1.25
Oh, that's still too much.
Let's make it.
about this
Okay, I mean it's still applying here, but I know I don't want
it to be this extreme.
And of course we can go the negative Direction.
Okay.
Let me go whatever is as much smarter number.
How about
what is this?
fine
Yeah.
So imagine you have an object.
Like in the video game and you want to make sure it has a shadow I
can use a Shear effect.
Now what if we want to create a plane our plane? Maybe let me borrow
this code again.
Paste it here.
And a matrix is
a
set of vectors set of row vectors.
So let's say we have the following.
We create a matrix m.
Initially you will be in mpls.
And now let's say we want to give this Matrix.
10 rows
it will be of
a row of
10 10 rows of vectors
All of them eight which each row would
be a vector which and will be 8.
points
It's like will be eight.
And I'm going to put each row inside the Matrix. So if I run this.
Okay. Oh, no, we're not going to see it just yet. But maybe this is a
if I type an m dot shape.
Okay, so we have 10 rows.
Two by two well, but this is a this is a list of two dimensions.
This is X and X and Y.
Okay.
I'll show you what I mean in a second now if I plot this
Matrix.
So I'm going to go.
here
alright
Let's make this hard or let's make
this V.
for each V in them for each Vector inside the
matrix by run this
So you can see here we have ourselves.
a plane
Okay.
Now if you wanted to look like a plane
like we see here.
I can close it. I can close the displacement. I want to
call if I close this placement here.
I can make them move in a fractions right now. They're moving
in increments of I think in one increments of
one.
but if I make this, you know one tenth
you can see now.
It's starting to look like a rectangle.
Let me make it a little.
increase in displacement you can see
let me go from 5 to 100.
to increase the width
Okay, maybe maybe.
Increase the space of the more let's go 150.
Yeah.
so now if I apply shoe to this like before
so I'm going to go here.
gonna copy paste this
copy paste that
and multiply this I'm going to go Ms up.
transform
multiply the sheet or matrix by the original
Matrix
I run this now.
So that's the original one. But if I say m transform
there we have now applied to the Matrix.
Okay.
So this linear transformation works for either the vector?
and the Matrix so after all Matrix is
just
you can imagine as a sequence of vectors but not necessarily
because if you have four points you can we can use the
fill between method.
To draw a plane. So we plot Four Points.
And then we can draw so maybe I'll show I don't have the code, but I'll I'll write
it down.
Okay.
I want to do an exercise now.
These are pretty straightforward. So if you want to shoot if you know
if you want to share left you right you can you just have to change this the sign for
example go from negative to positive and you can
make it slanted to the right.
just like, you know just like we see here and then what if we want
You know in this direction, well, we can just make the 0.
I mean, I think you already get the idea but let's you know.
I'm showing that side because I want to use that I want you to use that for this
exercise.
There we go. It's you know, that's just
share that direction.
These are pretty straightforward.
If you want to contract expand.
If you want to if you want to widen the Matrix, so
let's see what this looks like. Go back here. Turn it back
into an IDE Matrix and make this.
0.5.
Or let's make it 1.5.
You making it wider.
This we will use this later on we will use this this snippet
and develop it further.
Okay, let's do an exercise on.
This but I will use the other slide from
Cornell.
for reference
What is that rotation one?
Yes, so let's make this exercise but instead
of going from an identity Matrix.
For shearing or making it white. Let's
see if we can.
How we can rotate it, so you'll have to combine your knowledge
of polar coordinates.
And what we just talked about to accomplish this rotation.
So it will be a simple exercise.
I'll give you this code. Of course.
Let me save this as exercise 1.
Sorry, not exercise one we've done how many are how many
exercises have we done at this point?
We've done.
I thought we did more than one exercise.
I will tentatively call it to
in this exercise you
You will use this code?
to rotate a vector
rotate
the vector
v sub 1
by 45 degrees
90 degrees
so this is for your plot.
and
create a vector.
So this is a line segment. It will go from
0 0
0 10
okay.
So again, this is x sub 1
y sub 1
x sub 2 y sub 2 you
can literally copy the code from above.
And we need to have space on the y-axis. So
I'm going to make this go from negative 15.
okay.
so using
using the VEC function
create
this is Step. Number one.
step two
draw using
the draw function
draw the vector
on the figure
Again, the code is right up there.
Then step three.
Create a transformation matrix.
transformation
matrix to rotate
V sub 1
by 90 degrees
step 4
multiply
V sub 1
by the transformation matrix
transformation matrix
And let's call this one rotate.
Okay, so that's the name of the Matrix. Yes. That's
the name of The Matrix.
I'm going to color rotate.
In the P dot array something something.
Can you can do this like so you can go?
V1 stop B sub
1 rotate.
But essentially be NP document multiply
matrix multiplication.
and you want to multiply
the rotation Matrix
by
V sub 1
and step 5
draw the
rotated
vector
Now you actually need something. You need
to know something here.
On the hint here.
or
step four
hit
use the math.
library for the trigonometric functions
That's the first hint.
remember
switching
polar to Cartesian
Let me give you.
the transformation matrix
Which they have?
here
if you want to convert.
45 degrees
if you want to convert 45 degrees.
clockwise
sign will be negative.
If you want to rotate counterclockwise, and this
would be negative. Now. It doesn't matter if you go negative 490 degrees
or positive 90 degrees this way go 90 degrees either
direction.
All right, so
Let me give you this.
Code all right quickly. So this is going
to be the rotation Matrix.
Let's call it m sub rotate.
B Matrix
So we have cosine and sine.
It's only one of these side functions needs to be negative.
Amazing I didn't stick again.
This has to be cosine.
Yeah.
I don't like that in mathmatics. They don't put the parentheses.
I don't like this notation.
You have to put the parentheses because this is this is an argument of the
function. So I'm going to actually put the parentheses.
You know math.
is a
difficult to learn as it is no need to make
the notation.
obscure
There we
go. That's that's much better in my opinion.
Okay, let me give you this file.
So you want to create one of these matrices?
multiply to the vector
and
plot it
All right. So let's spend around 15 minutes
on this exercise again, you can literally use the
code up here.
For reference. I'm also going to give you this file.
This is relevant. By the way.
Not this one this one.
number eight
stop you I'll attached right
now. So this is
exercise 2
geometric
transformation
of vector
Download by the way, if you if you
you need these libraries, right?
If you don't have them.
There are two ways you can go about this. You can either activate this
code to install it so you can go python.
- M
pip install
PLT
NP but that assumes we already have Pip
if we don't
you can just use collab like before.
literally upload this file to collab and you can
carry on.
I'll give you the code the code to call
up.
Download the attached.
notebook
complete
the exercise
and see tutorial
I'll change the number in a second.
H4 reference I'll paste the link in a second.
note
you can use.
collab
for the sexual size
Okay.
Here's the notebook.
And the tutorial is actually on the dashboard.
It's not a dashboard.
It's number 10.
So go and download this.
Notebook. Just click on this download button.
Upload it to call app.
If you don't have Pip installed, I will attach
tutorial. I will give you the LinkedIn tutorial number 10
in a second. I'm just gonna I'll upload it very quickly.
So this is the link to tutorial 10.
if you refresh in a second you will get
some more comments
and if you want you can have
this example
you can you can okay, you don't have to you know,
see.
the example
or use the urban
okay.
let's spend around 10 not maybe 15
minutes because you need to
Check the code as well, and then we'll look at the solution together.
Okay, don't forget once you're done to and send the
solution to me directly.
Okay.
I will be with you in a moment.
you
question from
Ron and Richard Richard, I think I answered.
Yeah, so clockwise counterclockwise. It doesn't
really matter.
either 45 degrees
in quadrant to
I keep saying 45.
90 degrees did I say 90 or 45
here?
90 degrees 90 degrees. So basically you
want the light to be perpendicular to the origin to
V1.
so the transformative vector
perpendicular to
V1
can we just spec the rotation angle
as radians?
Sure, if you can if just get it make it.
Make it rotate 45 degrees.
So it is vertical make it.
rotate 45 degrees either clockwise or
counterclockwise
so whichever method
You think works you can try that?
Also want to show you something if it might help.
I'll type it here in a second.
No true. I wouldn't say anything. I was just
that's just my face when I'm talking. Let's look
at the solution together.
Because I actually kind of meant to make this I I
meant this to be.
Slightly tricky just I can specially enjoy
your attention if I can ask everyone to please send me send your
code, whatever whatever you have, even if it's incomplete and
even if there was a if there's error in your code.
Again, because this helps me gauge.
You know the pace the pace of our sessions, so kindly do please
attach me attach the files directly, please
to me and let me show you the solution.
Okay.
So let's do this together.
Before we run out of time. So I'm gonna do
two things. I'm gonna do these steps. I'm gonna
draw
my Vector V1, which is
for reference then.
I'll create a transformation matrix. I'll show you how to create a
transformation matrix, by the way.
So I'm going to create my vectors. I'm going
to go Vector. This is going to be V sub 1.
And it will take his argument a tuple.
So this will be 0 10.
Okay.
Again, I don't need to pass two two poles because by
default it's X and Y displacement is
zero anyway.
I just need to tell where the segment goes where
the second point is. So and that's
zero ten. This will give me that straight line like before.
Then I'm going to draw this Vector. I'm going to go draw the
sub one and
I'm gonna go obj equals ax and for the
color just want to make it black.
Because it's the reference effect vector.
Okay, make sure the other libraries are
imported. So I'm going to click on run all.
and then when I scroll down
There is the line now. I want to show you how to rotate this.
45 degrees
so I'm going to create my rotation Matrix.
And comment that line of code.
And if we look at if we look at the reference.
Up there it says that.
We need to have cosine and
sine and sine of cosine. So I already
have the math library in scope.
So I'm going to use math dot cosine. I'll plug
in the values in a second then I have math outside.
Then I have math dot cosine.
Whoops sine and then cosine, right?
The cosine's go on the main diagonal.
like so
what number should I plug in here?
And this has to be negative.
This is going to go.
Counterclockwise should be math. Yeah, but what no, what
should be the Theta what should be the argument for these functions?
radians
Okay, so
we can't put 90 because well.
We're not an Apollo coordinate system. So yes, we
would have to convert radian to.
Sorry degree to Radian.
If I show you the polar coordinate system.
polar coordinate of course Pi is the
length of the unit circle half of
that
would be 180 degrees.
So one unit circle is 360 Degrees half of that is 180. I
have a 180 would be a pi over
4.
Right, so but let me just pull up the picture.
Okay.
And there's actually two ways. I wanted to show you.
to solve this
but
Which one of these is clear. This is yeah. There we go.
Okay.
So Pi the length of the unit circle, so
three obviously this would be 360 zero and
360 are the same.
Pi over 2 was 180.
So half of a unit circle.
And then 1/4 of the unit circle.
So this L shape we get 90 degrees. Our Vector right
now is here our origin vector.
So we want to go 90 degrees clockwise.
It doesn't matter if you go left or right, but the point is to make it rotate 90
degrees.
So let me show you two ways to do this.
Kind of running from the ingredients so that
would be math.
Dot Pi Phi is a is an
attribute of the math object over 4.
So I'm just going to take this and I'm going to call it.
Theta
I will not pi over 4.
Don't know why it's saying this I I did import math up
here. Why are you
Okay, if I didn't if I did not input put this
in here, I apologize. I meant to put math in here.
Theta
data data
If you want to send me
this round just go to collab.
then
file
download and you have the option of downloading either format.
And by the way, we can even save it to your drive for for later
use so download.
IP okay.
There's my rotation Matrix. Let me activate this
code multiply my rotation as against my original
vector.
And then if I want to draw my Vector, I'm just going to go.
draw
V1 sub rotate
obj and x and the C. Let's
make it red.
and
I meant to make this pi over to there we go. No now
so here's the thing.
Okay.
I want to know before I do that. I want to show you something. I
want to show you them. Not the python implementation
because I want to make this as mathematical as possible.
if I take you
Yes, but let me show you something. Let me show
you something. If I come here back the tutorial Let me refresh this.
I want to use this implementation.
this one
So if you remember we said that if you want to convert from Polar to Cartesian.
I mean I already went through this in the start
of the session, but I want to go the other way around.
So I cannot plug in.
the degrees because we're not in a polar
coordinate system, so I have to
Convert the other way around now the radiant
will obviously it's this but I already know what the length of my Vector
is. It's just him so R is equal to 10.
But if I want to get my Theta I can use arctan. This
is the inverse trigonometric function. It is denoted
Octan or even ten to the
power y to the power negative 1
So these are these two are identical. Okay, sometimes you
will see this notation. Sometimes you will use that notation.
I'm going to use the archetype function to get
the Theta.
and to get that I'm gonna have to put y over 10, so my
Y is 10
and my X is
y x is well my x is 0
Okay, so let me show you how I'm going to do this.
All right.
So I'm gonna go.
theta equals math
Dot
arcad or A10
and the ratio is y over X. So that's 10 over 0
what? I cannot divide.
over zero
So let me just make it converged to zero make it
as close to zero as possible. So zero zero.
One, okay. I want to it's just an approximation.
Let me also print it.
And it gives me 1.57.
Now, why did they not apply? Why did
not do what I want?
That's it should have happened.
and
what what did I do wrong?
No, no, I used A10. I literally have it here in
front of me. I've sold it before.
Then what am I doing wrong here rotation?
It's literally the same code let me.
Let me see what I've done wrong here.
That's eight and that's it the array cosine.
sign
I mean look at this. This is exactly the same code I
had from before.
There it is.
same same
let me see what I've done wrong here.
Yeah, so there's multiple ways so we can convert to
read I just want to let me just focus here. Let me see what I've
missed here Matt tomorrow.
rotation back here
Thank you.
I plug in this number.
What?
What did I miss?
See because in order for this line to be.
flat
the y-axis must well, we must say it why
so why is it why Sub Zero y sub 1 should be 0
to stay on the slide ex. However must
go negative five points if I print V1
sub rotate and if I look at the elements,
so this is x sub 1 x sub 2
y sub 1 y sub 2
so this is incorrect. So, what did I do
wrong?
Here, there we go. That's my problem.
This is meant to be cosine.
Yeah, thank you. Tuba.
Okay. There we go.
This is what I was trying to do.
So yes.
I really wanted to show you this implementation because
so that we know we can we can first of
all to show you the purpose of the inverse trigonometric functions and
that this is one way we can convert back.
And go we can alternate from Polar quality
to Cartesian.
And the other solution is to use, you know,
the ones you've suggested which is the use the Radian.
so
what do I make what was supposed to do?
I make this pi over 2. So this is
first option
in the second method is to do it this way.
This is going from
polar
to Cartesian
and this is
degree to
Radian
Okay, let's try again.
And of course we want this to be 90 degrees. So I'm gonna make this
pi over 2.
There we go.
the okay, that is correct one, but
I was just trying to I cannot make this zero.
So I just made it very close to zero.
So and of course trigonometric functions, they
later Market. We need to
maybe later on. We'll talk about the sinusoidal function and talk
about the amplitude.
so
I will show you one late in another session or on a
separatory. I will show you the python implementation for trigonometric function.
So it will be able to handle the entire domain of
real numbers.
Okay, I have I already have that code I will maybe attach
it and it will go through it in a separate session. But I think
it will be interesting. Give us an assignment. Okay?
anyway
There is your solution.
This is solution or solution.
A that's one way to do it and solution B.
the other video
I think this is also useful when you want to
have automation.
automatically
imagine you have like an app.
And you moving you want to
like we're looking for Photoshop or get right? You want to apply Transformations, but
these are both both of them are solutions. Okay
everybody.
Our next session begins on Monday again
for those of you who joined later. I want to apologize for pushing it.
To Saturday. I know for some of you you picked
Sunday. Hopefully when you
watch tutorial if you have any questions, let me know but our
Yeah module 4, excuse me. This is
the end of module 3 module 4. We will talk we
want to switch to
diagonal matrices
we will revisit applications of computer vision if there's enough time
but we want to cover determinants characteristic polynomials
and then eventually singular validity
composition and a specific case of SVD, which
is PCA which is like if you I'm
sure you've seen session one, right? We said it has broad applications Finance
economics.
Many many applications PCA is especially machine
learning is is relevant. So we're going to work our
way up towards.
PC and its applications
until then
Thank you very much for joining me today.
And I hope to see you on Monday the exercise
assignment tool will be uploaded soon as well.
Before we started next week.
Thank you very much. New one. Thank you everybody.
Bye for now.